CHRIS BROADFOOT: Hi I'm Chris
Broadfoot, I work on the
Google Maps API.
ANDREW GERRAND: And I'm Andrew
Gerrand and I work on the Go
programming language.
And today we're here from
Google in Sydney to
demonstrate a HTML5 Google Maps
based web app that uses
the Go runtime on App Engine
to perform some intensive
computation in the cloud.
And before we get into the guts
of the app, I'm going to
get Chris to talk about
the problem our
app tries to solve.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So, this might
look familiar to you,
it's a map of the world
of satellite
imagery taken from space.
This here is also taken
from space.
And it's a cloud layer.
So this is available through the
Maps app and also through
the Maps API.
Late last year, Google Maps
Mobile added indoor floor
plans to the base Google Map.
So essentially, they overlaid
quite detailed indoor
information in context with
the map of the world.
Loughborough University has
done a similar thing, by
adding custom imagery on top
of the base Google Maps so
that their visitors can navigate
from the world and
also within the campus.
And so this is a Maps
API application.
So what you're seeing here is
kite imagery taken by Frank
Taylor on his Tahina
expedition.
So I think this is in French
Polynesia somewhere.
He's flying a kite up and taking
some aerial imagery.
And so, you can see a little
clearly where his really high
resolution imagery has been
meshed with the lower
resolution Google Satellite
imagery.
And so, if I zoom in all the
way, you can see how
detailed this is.
I think this is zoom level 22.
And you can see these two guys
riding their bike, someone
standing there, and a car.
So consider, maybe yesterday you
jumped out of a blimp, you
wearing Google Glass,
and you took some
really awesome imagery.
You'd want to get this onto
a map somehow, right?
Show it in context with the
Google Satellite imagery.
You can do this with
the Ground Overlay
class in the Maps API.
You essentially tell us where
the imagery is, and pass in
lat-long bounds.
So, a region on the earth,
essentially a rectangle.
And you end up with something
like this.
There's a trade-off between
size and high resolution.
So, here in this overlay we're
sending the whole image down
to the client.
So you'd either have to send a
large image to get really high
detail when you zoom in, or
suffer low resolution imagery
once you zoom in.
This is the same problem that
we have on Google Maps.
So consider that the width of
the world at a particular zoom
level is two to the
power of that zoom
level, times 256 pixels.
So, at zoom level 21 that's 536
million pixels, and that
turns out to be 288 quadrillion
pixels if you have
really high resolution imagery
at worldwide coverage.
So that turns out to be 40
petabytes, which is completely
unreasonable to send
down to a browser.
Even if you could send it,
they wouldn't be able to
render it, right?
So, the way Google Maps solves
this is by using tiles.
So at zoom level zero, at the
top the entire world is
represented by one tile.
And as you get further and
further zoomed in, more and
more tiles are used to represent
high resolution
imagery of the world.
So at zoom level 21, there's
many, many tiles.
So this same tile-based
approach could be
used for map overlays.
If you've used the map in the
I/O Android app, this uses the
same tile-based approach.
And indeed we generated these
tiles using the app that
Andrew and I will demonstrate
today.
So if you zoom in, you get a
really high resolution, sharp
image that matches the base
Google Maps tiles.
So it's really easy to add
this tile overlay.
You create an image map type,
you tell the Maps API where to
find the tile image for a
particular coordinate, and
then you add it to the
overlay map types.
Now the I/O Android map has
about 1,000 tiles for that
small area.
And you can imagine that
generating these tiles is a
little difficult.
So we have some really
great tools that--
these two are open-source and
they help you generate these
tile overlays.
So the first one, gdal.
gdal_translate essentially
encodes some location
information into the image.
So we can see here, we're
converting between pixel
coordinates and positions
on the earth.
And then we can use gdal2tiles
or the map tiler project to
generate a tile,
a tile pyramid.
Now, these tools are
really great.
But as I demonstrated at I/O
last year, it's quite
difficult to find those
precise coordinates.
So, I demonstrated an
application last year that
helps you with this.
But this year, we've got a
more complete solution.
So we've open sourced it, it's
called overlay tiler.
And you can download the
source code here.
But today, Andrew and I will
be showing you some of the
details about how we built it.
So let's jump straight
into a quick demo.
So, today we'll be adding
the Mosconi floor plan.
This is essentially what I did
a few weeks ago to generate
the floor plan for
the Android app.
So this is a floor plan that
we got from our vendor, who
did all the fit-out.
And so if I go and search
for Howard Street,
zoom straight in.
And then I'm just going to drag
the image from my desktop
onto the map.
And once I drop it, you'll see
that the image is added
exactly where I dropped it.
And I get these three control
points that I can use to drag
the image around the map.
I can also use this one
in the middle to just
translate it around.
And I can precisely and directly
manipulate the image
on the map to see what
it'll look like.
So I can also use this opacity
slider just to make sure it
lines up with the base
Google Maps Tiles.
Or perhaps if I'm going to
eventually put it Satellite
Mode, you can see it's slightly
offset, so I might
actually move it there.
And then hit the
Process button.
And from here the overlay is
uploaded along with its
coordinates to App Engine, where
App Engine will go and
generate a tile set.
And once that's done, I'll
download a zip file and all
the tiles will be in that
zip file, along with a
implementation that adds this
overlay to the map.
So if I go ahead and unzip
that, open up index.html.
So let's have a look inside
here at some tiles.
So these are the tile
coordinates.
So I can see part of
the Mosconi Center.
If I open up index, we see
that the overlay is
added to the map.
And we can zoom all the way in
and get high resolution tiles.
OK?
So we'll be showing you
some of the details
about how we built.
Just quickly, we used HTML5, the
Maps API and Go and Google
App Engine.
So, first of all, I'll start
with the user interface.
So the first thing you'll
notice the page is
filled with a map.
If you have a mapping-based
application, or an application
that's quite map-heavy, you
should go ahead and fill the
page with the map.
Nothing hurts me more than
to see a map-intensive
application that has
a really tiny map.
It's a horrible user
experience.
So the other thing is, if you're
giving your users a way
to navigate around the world,
add Places auto-complete.
It's really simple-- it's about
three lines of code--
and your users will
love you for it.
So, once the user has landed on
the page and navigated, we
drag and drop the image
to the map.
So we do this by listening
to the drop
event on the map element.
You can use any element
on the page.
And from there, we get a handle
to the file on the
local file system.
This is something that
traditionally, browsers
haven't offered access to.
This is a really great way
to perform client-side
manipulations.
You don't need to send this file
to the server to begin
using it, straightaway.
So we create an object URL,
which gives us a URL to the
local file system.
And create a new overlay at the
x and y-coordinates that
the user dropped the image.
So, to add the overlay to the
map, we use a Google Maps
overlay view.
So this is a class that you
implement, these three
methods, onAdd, draw,
and onRemove.
So draw essentially is called
when the overlay should be
re-rendered.
And getMap and getPanes
getProjection are really
useful to render the overlay.
So once the image is added
to the map, we
create an image element.
We set the source to the URL
on the local file system.
And we add it to the
overlay image pane.
You see at the bottom, we're
calling getPanes.
And this is a handle to some of
the map panes so that when
the map is panned,
your overlay is
translated with the map.
So once the overlay is added to
the map, you need to give
the users some way
to manipulate it.
We do this by adding three
control points, top left, top
right, and bottom right.
And for each one we
had a marker.
The user is able to drag it
around, and we use the bindTo
function to bind the position
of the marker to the control
point on that overlay, so that
whenever the marker is
dragged, the overlay's control
points are updated as well.
Now, whenever the user drags
the marker, whenever the
position of those markers
change, we need to re-warp the
image, so that they get
a really direct
manipulation feel.
We do this with an affine
transformation.
So, affine transformations are
four types of transformations,
translation, scaling,
rotation, and skew.
And so with those four
transformations combined, we
can do something like this.
And so this represents all of
the operations that you can do
based on three control points.
So using an affine transform, we
can warp the image whenever
the user drags the marker.
We use RequestAnimationFrame
to synchronize the paint
events of the browser with our
own paint events, and we set
the transform property
on the image.
So down below, you can see
the CSS property matrix.
And so this is the matrix that
represents the transformation
based on those three
control points.
And it's also the exact same
matrix that we'll be using on
the server-side later, and
Andrew will talk through that.
So when we first created
this app, we
dragged a large overlay--
I think it was tens of megabytes
or hundreds of
megabytes--
and the browser slowed
to a crawl.
This is because it was just too
much work to be able to
transform the this image
many times a second.
So when the user drags the image
to the map, we check if
it's larger than a certain
dimension.
And if it is, we just re-size
that image in the browser,
using Canvas.
Using Canvas, we can paint a
image to a canvas, and turn it
into a data URL.
And then we update the
source of the image
so it's scaled down.
While this is all happening, the
full size image is being
uploaded to Blobstore
on App Engine.
So as soon as the user drops
it, the image is uploaded.
But this immediately able to
manipulate the image, because
we have access to
that local file.
So we just upload in the back
end, and once the user's
finished manipulating, once
they press that Process
button, the three coordinates of
the control points are sent
to the server.
And the server starts
tiling the image.
Andrew will talk more about
what happens now.
ANDREW GERRAND: Thanks, Chris.
So now that we've seen the user
interface and how this
was constructed, I'm going to
talk about how the tiles are
processed on the back end and
the zip file is created.
So, as I mentioned at the
beginning of the talk, we're
using the Google App Engine
platform to build this app.
And who here has used
App Engine before?
Anyone?
All right, so those of you
who used it, who's
used the Go API before?
Ah, that's great.
So for those of you don't know,
the App Engine platform
is Google's platform as
a service offering.
That is, we take care of all
the infrastructure worries,
building it out, scaling it and
administering it, so that
you don't have to, and you and
your team can just focus on
building scalable, reliable
web apps.
In this application, we actually
use a variety of the
services available in App
Engine, and I'm going to talk
through some of that.
So, just an overview of
how the app works.
There are five main
parts of the app.
The first is the upload handler,
which receives the
file from the user and stores it
into the Blobstore Service,
which is a service for storing
large, unstructured data.
The second is the
process handler.
And this receives the set
of overlay coordinates.
That is, when the user has
positioned the overlay on the
map, it sends the latitude and
longitude of the top left, top
right, and bottom right
corners that overlay.
And the process handler takes
those coordinates, it takes
the original overlay image, and
then computes which tiles
need to be generated at what
zoom levels and the
coordinates of those tiles.
And then creates some tasks
which are fed to this next
handler, the slice handler.
And so the slice handler takes
these tile coordinates, and
the original image, and then
performs the transformation
that the user requested in the
first place using a external
package called graphics-go,
which provides an affine
transformations primitive which
is very convenient for
what we're doing.
And then it encodes each of
those new tiles as a PNG image
and stores them into
the data store.
Once all the slicing is
completed it kicks off another
task, the zip task, which
collects all of the tiles that
have been generated and then
generates the index dot html
file, that we saw earlier.
And then bundles all those files
together into a zip and
stores in into the Blobstore.
Finally the user is prompted
to download the zip file
through the download handler,
which simply serves the zip
file directly from Blobstore.
So, when describing any app, a
great place to start is with
data structures.
And our app has two very
straightforward data
structures.
The first is the overlay
structure, and these are both
the Go data structure
definitions, which map
directly to datastore
entity records.
The overlay struct represents
any given map overlay, so when
a user drags an overlay onto
a map along with the file
upload, we create a
overlay entity.
And the first field in
the overlay entity
is the image field.
And the image field is a blob
key, a reference to that image
in the Blobstore.
The second one is a zip blob
key, and that will be a
reference to the zip file,
once it's been created.
And then we have the pixel
coordinates of the top left,
top right, and bottom right of
the overlay which are used in
computing the transformation.
And finally we have the total
number of tiles that will be
generated, and we use that to
figure out when we're finished
generating all the tiles.
And the other data structure
that we have is the tile.
And a tile has an image field,
which is just a byte array,
which will have the contents
of our PNG map tile image.
And three other int 64 fields,
which are the x and
y-coordinates of the tile and
pixel coordinates, and the
zoom level at which this tile
should be displayed.
So now that I've given you that
overview, I'm not going
to walk through the entire
application piece by piece
because it would take probably
longer than we have now.
And a lot of it is minutia
that you can probably
understand fairly easily
on your own.
So instead we're going to talk
about some of the design
problem so we encountered when
building the app, and how we
went about solving
those problems.
So the first problem was
to make it reliable.
It's easy to write a program
that just runs from start to
finish, and if everything goes
well, then it's correct.
But in the land of computers,
things can and will go wrong
all the time.
And so we wanted to build this
app so that, if the sliced
process, for instance, failed
at any point, it would just
resume where it left off instead
of having to start all
over again.
In some of the more high
resolution overlays, we're
talking about thousands of
tiles being generated.
And it would be really
inconvenient to have to just
take the pot luck that it's
going to succeed to completion
every time.
So the solution to this was to
use some of App Engine's APIs
and build our app on top of
those reliable fault-tolerance
structures.
And the first of these is
the Task Queue API.
And so task queues are a way
of reliably scheduling and
running work in a fault-tolerant
way, and they
come in two different
varieties.
The first are push
queues, which are
used to start workers.
So, when a task is entered into
a push queue, it triggers
some work, it calls
an HTTP handler.
And pull queues, which are
consumed by workers, so
workers actively lease tasks
from pull queues, do the work,
and when it's complete,
they delete the
task from the queue.
In the Overlay Tiler app, we use
push queues to start the
slice and zip tasks on backend
instances, and we use pull
queues to track the tiles that
need to be processed.
And so slice process will
lease those processes.
The other piece of the puzzle
are App Engine backends.
And so, a backend is a special
type of app instance that has
greater memory and
CPU allowances
than a typical instance.
And they have longer request
limits, so you can do much
more longer-running processes
with backends.
We set up a slicer backend that
runs slice tasks, and the
slice tasks are triggered
by a push queue.
And each slice task will
lease tile tasks from
the tile pull queue.
And for each tile, it performs
the transformation, renders
the tile, stores it in the data
store, and then removes
the tile from that pull queue.
So you can imagine that the tile
queue is asking for work,
completing it, and then telling
the task queue system
that this work is done.
And gradually that tile queue is
consumed until it's empty.
And so in the diagram, at the
bottom, we see that the slice
push queue is triggering the
task as a whole, and then the
task is taking tiles out of
the tile pull queue and
turning them into
rendered tiles.
So, if a slice task at any point
fails, that's when the
task queues really come
into their own.
If my slice task just dies in
the middle-- say it's rendered
two tiles, but it leased
four from the queue.
The lease on those remaining two
tiles will expire, and go
back into the tile pull queue.
And meanwhile, another slice
task is being created by the
slice push queue.
And those remaining two tiles
be leased and the remaining
work to be done without really
skipping a beat.
So that's how we made
it more reliable.
The second issue was
making it faster.
And so, what we have here is
an embarrassingly parallel
problem, right?
We have one source of data
that's basically immutable,
that is, the tile overlay.
And then we have many, many,
many small jobs that need to
be run over that
piece of data.
So there's no reason that it
should be done in serial,
which is how we had
it originally.
So instead, we thought we would
just run multiple tasks
in parallel.
And fortunately, the design that
we have using task queues
made it trivial to run multiple
slots tasks across
multiple backend instances.
And to do this, all we needed
to do was configure our
backends to launch four
instances of the slice
backend, instead of one, and
to process four slice tasks
simultaneously instead of one.
And then in the process handler,
where we set up our
slice tasks, we just add this
little bit of code here, this
is the only added code,
is for loop.
And then we target each task
to each one of the four
backends, creating four
tasks instead of one.
And that's it.
And we got a four-times
speed up, and that was
all we had to do.
And that was quite nice.
But I'm not that easily
satisfied.
The slice process itself, it
requests tiles to be done, it
performs the computation to
generate and encode the tile,
and then it stores it
in the data store.
And then it repeats that
process again.
But there's no reason we should
wait for the datastore
put to complete before
moving on to process
the next set of tiles.
And so fortunately, Go's
concurrency mechanisms make it
really easy to do this.
And so this is a very
broad-brushstrokes idea of how
it worked without concurrency,
in the purely sequential way.
So you lease the tasks, you
render the tiles, store the
tiles in the datastore, and
then delete the completed
tasks from the queue.
And with concurrency, we still
have our original lease tasks
and render tiles in the task
queue, but now we have this
error channel, for rallying
Go routines.
And then we just launch our
storage and deletion parts of
the process in another
Go routine.
And if you're interested in
learning how this works and
more about it, Rob Pike is
giving a talk tomorrow
morning, I think in this
same room, called
Go Concurrency Patterns.
I highly recommend you attend,
it's a great talk.
But the net effect of this,
is in the case without
concurrency, we had this
sequential render and put,
render and put, render
and put.
And with concurrency, we were
able to render tasks basically
as fast as we could lease them
from the queue, and put them
all in the background
simultaneously.
And because the puts tended
to take less time than the
renders, it was always in
sync and caught up.
And with that, we got another
factor of two.
So with a net of about 15, 20
extra lines in our program, we
got an eight times speedup,
which is nice.
So another third design issue
that we had was knowing when
our tasks were complete.
So, when all the tiles been
generated, we need to know
that they're all done and
create the zip file.
But when you've got multiple
slots tasks all generating
tiles simultaneously, just
because one is finished
processing tiles, doesn't mean
that another one isn't still
going and still has
more work to do.
And it would be pretty bad if we
started creating a zip file
which didn't have all of
the tiles in it, right?
And another thing is we can't
just kick off the creation of
a zip file at the end of any
one, because we might end up
creating four zip files, and
that's a waste of work.
So to do this, we had
to manage state.
And in App Engine, there are
some bad places to keep state.
One of those places is in app
instances, which can just die.
And so there's no guarantee
that they'll stick around
they're not unreliable, but you
just can't rely on them.
But that memcache records may
expire at any time because of
the guarantees that memcache
gives you.
They guarantee consistency and
accuracy but they don't
guarantee that they'll
actually be there.
And similarly, we can't just
count the tiles in the client
and expect the client to do
the right thing, because
clients can be broken, or
malicious, or just disappear
at any time.
So the one good place
to keep state in App
Engine is in the datastore.
It's consistent, structured,
and a reliable place.
And fortunately we're
already using it.
So we just implement
this algorithm to
know when we're done.
So at the end of each slice
task, when a slice task is
finished processing tiles and
has no more work to do, it
does a query to count the number
of tiles that exist in
the datastore.
And then it takes that count,
and it compares it with the
total number of tiles
that it's expecting.
So we had a field in the overlay
that was a record with
the number of total tiles.
And if there aren't enough tiles
in the datastore, we
know that it's time
to keep slicing.
So we go back to the start and
try and find more work to do.
Otherwise, we check the
ZipRunning value in the
overlay record.
Actually, sorry, I omitted that
from the start, there's
actually a boolean field in
our overlay struct that
indicates whether we've created
a zip task or not.
And if a zip task is already
running, then we're good to
exit and shut down
this last task.
But if neither of these two
conditions have been
fulfilled, it means that all
of the tiles have been
generated, it's time to start
zipping up the tiles.
And so we add a task to the zip
push queue, and then we
set the ZipRunning flag to true,
in the overlay record,
and put it back into
the datastore.
So that is fairly
straightforward, but it's racy.
So if we tried to actually run
this, there's a chance that
two slice tasks could compare
the number of tiles and not
see that there's a zip file
running, but then create two
zip files simultaneously.
And so the solution to this
is to just run it inside a
datastore transaction.
And with the Go runtime, that's
as simple as creating a
function closure, which
encloses all of these
operations, and then
run with the
running transaction function.
And this even applies
to adding the
task to the task queue.
So task queues are incorporated
in datastore
transactions, and that's a
really nice mechanism.
And so our fourth and
final problem is
communicating with the user.
So, after the user has hit the
Process button, and all these
slice tasks have been fired off,
and the zip task has been
fired off, there's no back
channel to the user.
The backends are running these
instances and the user has no
direct communication
with the backend.
And not only do we need to tell
them when it's done, we
also need to tell them as it's
going, what the state of the
program is, so they have some
indication it's actually doing
something and not stalling.
So the means for doing
this with App Engine
is the Channel API.
And at the App Engine Channel
API just provides a push
channel from App Engine
instances
to the user's browser.
And the mechanism for doing
this is really simple.
There's just two functions on
the server side, there's the
create function and
the send function.
And so the create function
just takes an ID of your
choosing, which uniquely
identifies the channel.
And then returns a token, which
you pass to the client.
And the client uses some
JavaScript create that channel
using the token.
And then sending a message, you
just provide the client ID
and the message you want to
send, and it's any textual
string that you can send
to the client.
And on the client side, there's
some JavaScript, you
just create a new channel object
and open it, which
returns a socket.
And then the socket has an
onmessage handler, which, when
called, will pass a
message object.
And so this code will just log
the message to the console
every time a message
comes through.
And there are also some other
handlers to detect the opening
of the channel, the closing of
it, and errors and so on.
So in our app, Go's support for
JSon encoding of native
data types makes it really
clean and nice.
We just define a message struct,
which is the structure
of the message we want to
send to the client.
And then we use this send
JSon function to send a
JSon-encoded version of the Go
data structure to the client.
Now, our message struct
contains four fields.
The first is the total number
of tiles in the overlay.
And the second is a list
of ids of tiles
that have been processed.
So in this second code snippet
here, this is what we do after
processing a bunch of tiles.
We send a message to the client
that contains the total
number of tiles and the ids of
those tiles, and then the
client adds them to a list
of tiles that it's
keeping track of.
The other two, fields TilesDone
and ZipDone are just
boolean flags to indicate what
are the stage of the process.
So once all of the tiles have
been computed and the slice
task has detected this, it
sends this message, just
setting the TilesDone equals
true, with send JSon.
And then the final message that
the client will receive
is the ZipDone message, so we
just send a message with
ZipDone set to true.
And on the client side, we set
up a channel by opening the
socket and register
a message handler.
And in the message handler, we
JSon decode that message and
check the fields of the message
to see what kind of
message it is.
So if ZipDone is set to true, we
redirect the user's browser
to the zip file.
If TilesDone is set to true,
we display a creating zip
archive message.
And ids is set, it means that
we're getting progress
information about the tiles
that have been computed.
And so we add those ids to
a object named tiles.
And this object just collects,
it's essentially a set of all
of those tile ids.
And this means if we receive ids
more than once, because a
task has failed in some way,
it means that we're not
counting tiles more than once.
We won't end up showing 110% of
tiles being computed, say,
if we received messages
more than oce.
So it's just a form of
deduplication, essentially.
And so we display a percentage
of the number of tiles that
have been computed
in that case.
So now we'll just
demonstrate a--
Do you want to?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So hopefully
the demo gods
will shine upon us.
ANDREW GERRAND: Well, they
shined upon Sergei yesterday,
so this is a much smaller ask.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I'm far less
worried than he was
yesterday, as well.
[LAUGHS]
ANDREW GERRAND: So now we're
going to try a bit of a bigger
image, which is Gotland, off
the coast of Sweden is it?
And this is from USGS's--
what's the project called?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I think it's
called The World As Art.
So they've got some really
beautiful satellite imagery.
This is one of my favorites,
it's called
Van Gogh from space.
So it's a photo of this island
and it's just some really
amazing imagery.
So if I go ahead and search for
Gotland, not Scotland, and
drag and drop this image.
You can actually see this
progress bar moving, so I was
able to manipulate the image.
I didn't, but it was just up
uploading in the background.
And I can just position it.
It's probably better to go into
satellite mode for this
one and not back the opacity.
Maybe if I zoom out--
I'll just get it, I'm
not going to spend
too long doing this.
Apparently Andrew is much
better at this than me.
ANDREW GERRAND: Just do it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Looks good, OK.
Let's hit Process.
This is quite a large
overlay, actually.
ANDREW GERRAND: So now you can
see it's processing tiles.
And if we look at the instances,
you can see there
are four slice instances
that are being spun up.
And if we look at the
task queues--
it's refreshing now--
at the bottom you can see
that there are 1,100
tasks in the queue.
And 180 have been leased
in the last minute.
And so if we keep refreshing
while that's going, you see
we're up to 17% now.
More tasks have continued to
be leased, so they're being
consumed from the queue
as it churns through.
And we have the four instances
still running.
And you can see their
CPU time--
they're actually nor working
that hard, it must be data
sort dominated.
And then if I refresh the logs,
so we can actually see
the active backend requests and
log messages being pushed
through from the backend
in semi-real time.
And so each one of these 10
tiles messages means that 10
tiles have been computed.
And so we can see it's
nearing completion.
Oh, and I should also note you
can see in the slice queue,
there are four tasks in the
queue and there are four
running simultaneously.
So that's our four
slices going.
And you see there's actually
been one or two errors there,
and they've just been gracefully
restarted and
picked up again.
And so now the zip archive is
being created on the backend,
and it should be served to us.
And then appear in our
downloads, which is this one.
Is that it?
Let's check the tiles.
No, that's not one.
It's this one.
So now if I open the index dot
html, I'll see the overlay on
the island.
So if I zoom in, I'll start
to see the greater detail.
Cool.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So, I just
want to talk a little bit
about the reasons why we chose
Go to do this, as opposed to
the Python or Java runtimes
on App Engine.
So, first of all, Go has great
standard packages, which we
took full advantage
of in this app.
Next is their great external
package support, driven by
really vibrant open-source
community.
And we used a graphics Go
package just to perform the
affine transformations.
And that package is actually
built atop the it built-in
image packages.
And then there's this great site
go.pkgdoc which you can
visit to get a list of the
thousands of packages that are
available--
of varying degrees of
quality, of course.
The main reason for choosing Go
on App Engine for this task
is that it's the only App Engine
run time that lets you
run this user-provided code
in native machine code.
So you get the full performance
of the machine
that it's running on.
It's not running on a virtual
machine, it's not virtualized,
it's just real code running
on real cores.
And so you can really crunch
some serious numbers with Go
on App Engine.
And finally, I think
I was just a great
language all around.
It's simple in its design.
The language and the libraries
are consistent and easy to use
when combined.
It makes for a very
comprehensible and cohesive
programing experience.
And also, Go provides some great
concurrency primitives.
And as we saw very briefly, I
was able to get a factor of
two performance increase in
my App Engine app just by
introducing a small amount of
concurrency in one of its core
components.
So the code for this app is
available in a Google Code
project, overlay-tiler.
And you may want to wait a few
minutes because we're going to
push an update just
after this talk.
If you want to learn more about
the Maps API, visit
developers.google.com/maps.
And similarly, to learn more
about App Engine this is the
same domain slash App Engine.
And to learn about Go, visit
golang.org which contains a
wealth of documentation as well
as an interactive online
tutorial, and some
other fun stuff.
So thanks everyone for the
coming along today, on behalf
of Chris and I. If you have any
questions we'll be happy
to answer them now,
but thank you.
Just step up to the mic if
you want to ask anything.
Or not.
Or you just all go to
the next thing.
No?
Cool
AUDIENCE: Just curious about
how much compute power you
used on that exercise in terms
of translating it to--
ANDREW GERRAND: To costs?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, cost or
running it on your own
servers, sure?
ANDREW GERRAND: So, my
understanding is these App
instances cost--
and the don't quote me-- but
it's somewhere in the realm of
$0.10, $0.15 an hour because
they're at the highest ones
that we have.
But again, I'm not a 100%
sure on the cost.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Can we look
at the cost in the logs?
ANDREW GERRAND: We probably can
but I don't want to, for
reasons you know about.
Not because it's high, but
because it shows some internal
stuff because we're logged in
as our Google.com addresses.
But you notice that there are
four instances running now.
And because they're dynamic
instances, they'll actually
only stick around for
5, 10 minutes max.
And so you actually only pay
for a fraction of that hour
for a bursty kind of
job like this.
And said backends can either
be configured to run
continuously, in which case you
just pay a constant rate,
or if they're dynamic,
they'll just spin up
when they're needed.
And then they'll spin down.
And you can actually control
when backends are started and
stopped programmatically, as
well, using specially formed
HTTP requests.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can Cgo work with
this on App Engine?
ANDREW GERRAND: Sorry,
can Cgo?
So, the question was does Cgo
work with App Engine.
And Cgo is a function call
interface for calling into C
code from Go code.
And the answer is no, the Go
App Engine runtime only
supports Go code, because the
memory safety that we get from
Go is what allows us
to run your code
safely on our servers.
Otherwise we wouldn't have
that security, C is a
fundamentally unsafe language.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Just curious about
what kind of errors do you
get, for example, for those
kind of task most times?
Because it doesn't seem to be
that, it seems to be a bit
frequently.
And what kind of errors?
ANDREW GERRAND: So, typically
the kind of errors that we see
are in some cases, out
in memory errors.
So if you have a particularly
large overlay and then you
slice a large number of tiles,
if, in some cases the garbage
collector hasn't caught up,
your app instance could be
killed because it's
run out of memory.
And we haven't seen a lot of
that, we've seen a few
instances with some really
big overlays.
Other things can happen are,
because App Engine is
distributed across multiple
data centers, you can
sometimes end up with hiccups
in the network, where a
particular datastore request,
a put or a get, will be hung
for longer than a particular
request deadline, and then
your instance will be killed.
It's basically just because
you working on a large,
distributed system.
We guarantee consistency,
but we don't guarantee--
I don't know how to phrase
it properly.
I probably should know.
But yeah, basically in any
system, you get errors that
you don't expect, right?
So you have to design it
assuming that any particular
part will fail.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm actually the
developer of nettiler that you
mentioned earlier.
And I'd like to ask
you, what's the
intended use of the system?
Is it something public
or is it something
internal for Google?
And if it's public, what's the
biggest size of image that you
are able to process
or what is it that
you have tried already?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So
we definitely
designed it to be public.
So the source code is completely
available and--
ANDREW GERRAND: But as a
service, we didn't design it
to be launched as a Google
service or product.
It's really just a pedagogical
exercise in learning about the
Maps API and learning about
Go on App Engine.
AUDIENCE: So if I wanted to,
I could run it on my own
instance of App Engine.
ANDREW GERRAND: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: It's not
a Google service.
OK, I understand.
ANDREW GERRAND: We were
running it on a public
instance now, but for the
purposes of our demo it's not
available to you all.
It adds a level of
unpredictability.
But we do intend to open that
up for people to use.
But anyone's free to deploy it
wherever they want as well.
AUDIENCE: And the question
about the image size.
What is some upper limit made
that you have tried or
something like that?
ANDREW GERRAND: So the biggest
images we've put in have been
between like 15, 20 megabytes
as a JPEG.
And so image size, that's
approaching about 10,000
pixels on a side.
Between 7,000 or 8,000
pixels, maybe.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's really
bounded by the size of the
instances that we're
running on.
So as Andrew mentioned, we were
running into some memory
issues on larger overlays.
ANDREW GERRAND: But nothing
that we weren't able to do
solve in the end.
So I think ultimately the upper
bound of the image you
can load is one that you could
decode within the memory
limits of a large App
Engine instance.
And I think the limit is 1 gig,
you would have to check
the website to be sure.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is the workflow
like in developing and
debugging an app that
is written in Go
and runs on App Engine?
ANDREW GERRAND: Right, so the Go
App Engine SDK is built on
top of the Python SDK.
So it comes with the same
development app server that
you can use to run Python
apps locally.
And so when you work on your
Go app, you launch the
development app server and it
will automatically compile
your Go app and run it.
And then you can just
access it via
local host, in a browser.
If you make changes to your Go
source code, the code is
recompiled.
And so you get the same kind of
edit, refresh, test cycle
that you get with scripted
web apps.
And because Go code tends to
compile usually in sub-second
times, usually sub
100-millisecond in some cases,
you don't really notice the
difference between that and
working on Python apps.
In deployment it all feels
exactly the same as the other
Python platforms.
It uses the Python app cfg
tool for deployment.
And one thing that's probably
worth mentioning is if you
have existing Python or Java
App Engine apps, you can
deploy backends that
run Go code.
So if you already have some user
interface, you can write
your heavy-lifting code in Go
and just have a hybrid set up
like that, and there's
no issues there.
Cool, well if there are no other
questions, thanks again
everyone for coming along and
I'll see you at the rest of
the conference.